Elias is here he's gonna be the special
musical guest of of Wrestlemania this
Sunday which is very very exciting Jim
you've never met allies I have not no
he's a big man he's musically talented
he's an athlete he's incredible here he
is looking glittery scarf on this early
in the morning Elias hello there I made
it yeah great I'm coming up to the desk
here great intro thank you very much of
course walking into that yeah well
welcome in so when you do you do have to
have I see you've got your scarves on
your wrists all my accessories that's
right the scarves the bracelets the
bandanas I got it you have to buy them
in bulk
just in case they tear anything or do
you or do they survive pretty well they
do pretty well they hold up pretty well
but I kind of spot shop you know if I
see something I'm in Paris or something
again I see a bracelet I want to go grab
it or wherever I'm traveling through if
I see a cool scarf I'll just pick it up
I guess you have that creative freedom
like you can show up with kind of
whatever scarf you want is to have there
been any scarfs that you show up with
and they go
you can't walk to the rain wearing that
huh so far no no they can wear whatever
and they've been okay with it right what
kind of music do you play
so I mean personally I love to play like
blues slash country nice to meet you but
unless be blues country that's kind of
my my vibe there just like Johnny Cash
Bruce Springsteen like that kind of
stuff yeah
did you because you're like the musician
bad guy wrestler character is something
that's been done for four years and and
lots of people have done it successfully
but I was thinking about it and I think
that you're the only one that could
actually play like the role has always
been I'm gonna pretend like I'm a
musician and we all know that you're not
and that's why we're booing you're kind
of the only one that walks up there with
the guitar just plays and sings and yes
thank you for pointing that world know
that yeah I'm the only one that's ever
actually played their instruments when
they went out there and
you know guitars my my number one but as
you know piano drums whatever I got to
do I'll throw that in the mix so what
you want to do before you wrestled you
want to be a musician no others wouldn't
be a wrestler actually and then music
just kind of came along in the in the
throughout my life so I get to blend
them both as I do this
do you always wanted to be a wrestler
yeah I was always wrestling for sure man
I heard you were not big in high school
um you know told me that Pat McAfee ha
bat loves to bring that up yeah yeah he
said you cuz Elias for those they can't
see right now is it he's a giant of a
man jim big arm big everything
thank you one fella large guy yeah you
know I was oh I was I was a skinnier kid
I probably was maybe a hundred and
seventy 165 pounds when I graduated I
was like playing baseball all the time
always running around that kind of thing
but you know when I decided wrestling's
what it's gonna be it was you know eat a
lot of food lift a lot of weights try
and get in the best shape you can and
that's kind of what I follow all the
time now how long did it take you to
actually feel like okay I'm a big dude
now geez man I still don't feel like I'm
big enough I gotta get bigger yeah you
hang out with giant people that's true
right you know some of these guys I'm
where I'm a big guy to normal people but
yeah you know to the guys I'm in now you
know I might just be right in the mix
you ever get frustrated when you're
sitting there and people are watching on
TV
and then because you're paired up with
guys that are equally as big they're not
sitting there going normal sized dudes
yeah yeah for sure a lot of times what I
find is uh if people see me in real life
if they're if they're blessed enough to
see me in person yeah yeah wow you're a
lot bigger in real life that I than I
thought you would be so when you when
you I guess realized that music is gonna
be a big part do you present the fact
that you can perform music to WWE and go
this is something I can do yes so it
actually kind of started I was having a
conversation with the legendary Dusty
Rhodes I was just talking to him about
my life and and who I am and what not
sure enough the next time I talked to
him I brought a guitar in I told a
little story to him about my life while
I was strumming and he was
that's it right there did he wonder why
in the conversation you pulled a guitar
out or did he know that guys seen it all
he ain't surprised by nothing you know
what I mean so uh yeah he was just he
was just interested and I you know when
I showed up on Monday Night Raw Vince
McMahon he wanted to know you know what
what am I getting into what is Elias
here and I went into his office and I
said Vince put your cell phone away hold
your applause until after I'm finished
and shut your mouth
you did that in a private meeting with
Vince yeah this was just a one-on-one
with Vince and sure enough I played him
a song and he said oh yeah this is gonna
be good that's pretty gutsy cuz that if
it works it's like you have this vision
and of course it worked you got to show
some balls and go in there but if it
doesn't work it might be the dumbest
thing you've ever done
sure right no but I had the confidence
that it would be good yeah and so did he
so what is it is it more nerve-wracking
to play guitar for somebody like Dusty
Rhodes or Vince McMahon when you're
trying to prove what I can do
or is it nerve-racking when you get in
front of a stadium full of people that
are there to see a wrestling show and
you must not think that's a great
question yeah I guess in the one-on-one
scenario a lot more just so personal
that it's I don't know yeah because now
at this point man all the the arenas and
the crowds that I've played in front of
that's just natural I mean if there's
one guy if you looked at his watch or
Yaya you have to notice it you can't not
notice that exactly exactly I guess
that's a kind of pressure
yeah let's like on those talent shows
where you watch them try to have
stand-ups perform in front of two people
yeah and you're like you're just having
a stand-up just do a show you gotta cut
your teeth in all different ways yeah
it's doing it in front of a couple of
people is a lot harder to do it in front
of five hundred or a thousand or more
yeah it is too personal yeah and I guess
the freedom to of being a villain is
that if you screw up in front of an
arena full of people and they start
booing you you're still ahead of the
game you're still doing fine oh don't
matter to me that's a matter of course
yeah I've never screwed up I just go
with it it is what it is it's all how
it's supposed to be done yeah so you
don't do you find yourself going like
okay let
I want to be a musician I want to be
taking more seriously for my music do
you find yourself going you know I feel
like I'm playing more music than I'm
wrestling which or the orgies feel like
you found the comfortable medium um you
know I I go back and forth between that
sometimes I'm like okay this is right
where I would be and it's where I'm for
instance like I'm playing my music and
doing that but I'm also feuding with
Seth Rollins all right something like
that I'm like okay that's where I should
be
now less I've always wanted to be a
wrestler so that's what I I love to do
you know what I mean
in the music thing is just like a
passion that I have as well so that's my
ideal scenario when I get to perform
it's equally as fun it's just I also
love the wrestling but do you play when
you're not wrestling to you like just
Gandhi shows no no no it's everything's
WWE my my top my entire existence
I mean I've rebranded the company if you
haven't heard that WWE stands for walk
with allies of course I don't know it's
just so weird for me to see people who
can do more than one thing well because
I got like I can't do anything well so I
sit there like I feel like if I had the
ability to do any type of music for
example yeah I would want to show the
whole world I'm like the greatest
musician ever I don't just focus on the
music look how good I am doing this cuz
this is the thing that you can't do
that's not enough for me I gotta show
them I'm the best musician in the world
and the best wrestler you know I got to
just show it all I see I guess I guess
that makes sense when musicians you have
to be good too because most of them
don't play music like they're all
wrestlers so the fact that you could do
something that almost none of them can
do oh yes it's true you're within WWE
I'm absolutely the greatest musician I'm
talking on a world yeah sure sure you
know right right do you sit there do you
do you look at musicians yeah and
actually go like I'm like if I were just
a musician I think I'd be better than
that person well you know I've seen
concerts and things like that and I'm
like you know what like jeez I should
throw this out there I shouldn't throw
the names out there who I just recently
saw and I was like you know what I'm
better than the highest is better than
this well you should we give you an
honest who did you see I saw Mumford
inside
[Laughter]
yeah that's also one of those things
that I feel like you know a lot of
wrestlers are sitting there going what's
life gonna be like after wrestling your
body can only go for so long and and and
at some point you have to figure out
okay the physicality just isn't gonna
happen anymore you can kind of play
guitar forever right I would love to I
guess as long as my hands and brain work
Yeah right should be able to write so
yeah that'd be a fantastic thing to
follow up wrestling with so do you
you're the you're the musical guest for
Wrestlemania this headlining musical act
I just as the headliner we'll just leave
it at that the head yeah the headlining
musical act I mean Joan Jett is gonna be
there performing super you are exactly
the headlining musical act Joan Jett is
she playing does she tie in somehow
she's playing around around oh she is
yes I was the same way I was like when
they were just like Joan Jett is gonna
be at WrestleMania I was like yeah was
that Conor McGregor had Sinead O'Connor
sing the national anthem once which I
understand it makes sense it's Italian
but you go well I'd like to have a match
at WrestleMania yeah and one day of
course that is absolutely on the agenda
but right now to be kind of given this
opportunity WWE hired me to be their
headlining musical act yeah man I mean
it's gonna be awesome MetLife Stadium
80,000 plus people coming out to see the
Elias concert it's gonna be good when
you go when you have an opportunity like
you've got right where you're one of the
the like you're the headlining musical
activist Oh mania thank you but you get
segments every week on TV
clearly the act is working in the sense
that you get big crowd reactions every
time you go out like everything is going
well and the company's behind it is
there that thing inside of you that goes
like oh my god I'm gonna do something to
screw this up oh my god this is all
gonna end well you know I try to be
prepared for like any and all situations
they throw at me right whatever segments
it might be on television or whatever it
might be in front of the crowd I just
try to make the best of whatever comes
my way as long as I'm doing that man
if I screw up if I mess up you know what
that's life it happens and I'll deal
with it when that happens
because you were kind of thrown in you
know a lot of guys they come up from
WWE's developmental system which is NXT
and they come on the main roster with
the character that they were doing their
know and for whatever reason it doesn't
work it doesn't click with the audience
it just doesn't have the same sort of I
don't know if emphasis is the right word
but it just doesn't work as well as it
did on NXT and and you know you watch
guys that you go out they thought this
was gonna go really well and they're
kind of lost out there it doesn't do
well with everyone sees it doesn't okay
it doesn't it just happens why do you
suppose the the the Elias character
breaks that rule and actually is worked
in your big way bigger now than you ever
were yeah they're no absolutely uh I
guess a couple I guess a couple things
one I feel like they only got me in a
small dose on NXT right they only saw me
here and there whereas on Monday Night
Raw in front of the world I get they
really expressed myself and kind of show
the things I can do
secondly from a character standpoint it
was like a natural evolution right I was
the drifter in NXT kind of this you know
traveling musician more or less and then
Here I am I landed on Monday Night Raw
now you're a rock star now I'm a rock
star right and you know it's the
spotlight it's bigger this is what it
should be so you know those two things
and just an incredible will to succeed
on my own part has made me that do you
do you prefer singing about songs about
towns and why they suck or why they're
great because you've got back and forth
good guy Elias goes out there and he's
like oh I love this town and here's a
song about it and then one we can just
show up and you're like wait I just
remembered hold on yeah I guess I gotta
stop you real quick please I would love
for you to go back and find me saying I
love this town let me sing a song about
it huh that's not the case now if you're
referring to the yeah I don't think
you're gonna find one of those now if
you refer to this like short timespan
where I was perceived as a good guy
Sheriff people were cheering on TV well
people cheer people
Elias good/bad no matter what you want
to label it ice but that was just a test
I was just testing okay I was gonna say
you know what if I'm not so mean for a
little while do you give me all the
respect and admiration that I deserve I
see and they let me down so I said you
know what no forget it forget it
I'm gonna being a nice guy right I'm
back to telling you how much your town
sucks exactly I see now think isn't it
fun to say that to people it's the best
shitty they are awful the place they
live in is great you should see how mad
people get when a guy goes up there he's
got a guitar and he starts singing about
how bad their football team is oh they
hate it it's got to feel good too
when you go up there especially because
you know that on some level they love
you when you can figure out how to make
those people that when you go out there
and they're cheering you and then you
actually get them to boo you based on
what you're saying that's gotta feel
amazing sure yeah well you know I'm just
you know I just play with the crowd
right it would take him up or down
whatever I got to do but do you remember
the incident in Seattle by chance of
course okay that was like such a moment
where I wasn't even saying anything for
maybe six or seven minutes and they're
just non-stop screaming booing as loud
as they can with all of their heart and
I'm just sitting there what was it do
you it was like one line that you
started with right that just stopped
everybody in their tracks yes it didn't
make sense it didn't make sense for
there to be a basketball team in Seattle
whatever they must be diehard you know
classic supersonic fans
so when something like that happens
right and they go like oh my god listen
to this reaction yeah you just have to
know cuz it's not like they tell you
okay you're gonna go out there you're
gonna insult the town and say they
shouldn't have a basketball team and
then they're gonna boo you for six
minutes like that that would be the most
insane wishful thinking in the world do
you just have to go I'm just gonna sit
in this for as long as humanly possible
and trust that the production people in
the back are just slowing everything
down and allowing this to happen well
you know I yes and no that's a tough
balance you know what I mean that crowd
was just so
overwhelming so powerful that it's like
I'm not even gonna try to power through
this you know what I mean because
theoretically you're not supposed to go
six minutes in that moment no yeah and I
get yelled at all the time for how much
time I take up on television but but in
the end they know it is good television
so you know it's like that balance right
there yeah yelled at for taking too much
time and then the next week they're like
okay we got you in this segment and that
segment and this segment the best when
you get that you find that what do you
guys have pride in and then you know
you're going to attack it that's often a
question I'll ask the locals you know
what I mean exactly don't you wish you
could you that is a stand up like that
it wasn't like you go up there and just
insult a town just nothing better team
sucks because you know it bothers people
on a visceral level I don't know why it
bothers people when you insult their
town or you insult their team but people
really get upset about that [ __ ] well
you grow up in the city and you know
you're just everybody supports a certain
cause and it's a good feeling and things
like that and then you have somebody
come by and say everything you believed
in is just garbage especially when
you're an outsider yeah you're way
bigger than they are
right you got a sparkly scarf on it's
just everything is just this guy is not
the guy that should be telling me how to
live and that everything I know I mean
you remember a
show that we won't say what the show was
but it was a show that was centered in a
bar that needed help and and when we
went in and the people realized that we
were associated with that show and then
it wasn't necessarily portraying their
local bar in the best light okay
everybody in that place hated us they
hate it we walked back here like a
little boo boo and yelled us while we
were shooting oh my god
finish wraparound segments whatever one
at the end is she [ __ ] booed and
yelled at us it was what are you doing I
didn't think we were but they felt like
their local thing was being insulted by
outside this may be a total rat infested
dump but it's our rats exactly bring
that to life yeah it's like family like
you sit around like you know insulting
your family and then some other guy goes
what what just say that do you have is
that your favorite moment that you've
had so far being in WWE or
I mean you've had a lot last year at
WrestleMania yeah if I remember
correctly did your musical performance
and you were interrupted by John Cena is
that correct
right yeah that's huge that was big yeah
now the thing is I I stole Undertaker's
moment and then which is also like
massive yes right and then John Cena
kind of came in he took my moment so
right but man I've honestly I've had so
many amazing moments the Seattle one
just stands out because it was just a
big television moment but the live
events I do and traveling overseas some
of these crowds they're just so
passionate they're so fun to be in front
of how did John Cena interrupt you was
that a mistake he didn't realize you're
playing probably that you know I'm out
there singing a plane he just randomly
decides okay I'm gonna go out there by
the time he's out there it's too late
you gotta do something right yeah yo
he's wonder why would they make this
mistake they put on John Cena's music
I'm playing right now do you sit there
so you grew up a wrestling fan obviously
yeah I wanted to be so do you sit there
as a guy who grew up a wrestling fan
after something like that and go oh my
god
when you run down this segment its
Undertaker John Cena and Elias that's
what this segment was like do you just
kind of sit back at moments like that
and go Jesus Christ this happened
I mean I'm aware of it I'm like I'm
definitely aware of like where I'm at
what my career's done the things and
stuff I've seen but it's so on to the
next thing
yeah I mean so it's like you do
WrestleMania and man whatever that'll be
awesome but guess what Monday night
Raw's the next night let's go do that
and then guess what we're on the road
again and now we got two weeks and
Europe or whatever it is so I try to
enjoy it just every second even every
second that I'm out there live and doing
it and take it in when I'm done and then
it's on to the next thing right then
you're also always kind of thinking
about what's now and also what's
tomorrow absolutely there's always a
what's tomorrow yeah do you work out
more than three times a week yes that's
probably I'm doing wrong yeah okay I was
like okay yeah you drink like soda and
eat shitty McDonald's I do not
a little Dietary tip okay you're right
that went down that's another day Sam
has been working out three times a week
though yeah three times a week 45
minutes at a clip so I think pretty soon
you and I will be right along oh my god
no major dietary changes but we go you
know babies are so small exactly exactly
doing the right things right right I
mean you I'm sure did you start small or
did you just dive right into it like I'm
just gonna start lifting weights and
eating tremendous amounts of food that
is kind of a moment that I had right
there but I started small just as well
was just back when I was a teenager
right now do you what do you eat right
to get all those calories can you eat
whatever you want because you're all no
no definitely not I mean I'm all it's
gonna sound so boring but I like you
know I eat a lot of chicken and steak
and I love sushi so I'm big on sushi
fruits vegetables trying to have like a
well-rounded meal CSS boring hear that
but I ate like a grilled chicken breast
for dinner last night do you think I'm
on the right track
do you eat more than one a day yeah that
makes sense to me how many how many
girls chicken breast would you eat in a
day maybe three to four something that's
just a portion of my day for sure and
that's just I like to start a day off
maybe ten to twelve eggs oh my god F in
that way okay and then you know move on
to the chicken and the steak and the
Sufi that's an ideal day so what do you
do before your arrests are making a ton
of money they can afford to buy a dozen
eggs for breakfast every morning and eat
like this when you're just a kid with a
dream who wants to get big and then you
start to get big but you get big before
you get rich and famous how do you
figure out how to afford like eating a
week's worth of food every single day
I've well for me I had like a side job
and I was pretty broke with it right so
I'm just doing what I had to do to get
where I had to get so that's so not fun
to have a job and all your money just
goes to breakfast eight twelve eggs a
day oh my go - I'm just shovel
oh no no I'll go wherever on the road I
definitely can't make anything right
everything so you'll pop into like a
deli or something to go I need 12 eggs
yeah like a big Cracker Barrel guide on
the road for sure about you know 11 12
eggs over-medium
Gregor right that's amazing that's
amazing yeah and I guess as it become
easier I feel like there's more people
that are health conscious and kind of
aware of different people's nutrition in
terms of eating on the road and figuring
it out um I don't know easier I mean in
terms of like there's more knowledge out
there and things like yeah for sure it's
never totally easy to make the right
decisions because you're always gonna
have like there's the gas station
there's Wendy's there's whatever you
know what I mean and so it's really
about just making the right decisions
yeah that's the thing a lot of times
I'll be driving past a Wendy's and I'll
go again be a good stop I should just
pop in there and then I do it's it's
difficult to choose not to do that ya
know Wendy's is great I just you know
you can't always be eating that if
you're trying to be in shape I have a
good time I don't I do well with food I
make great food decisions
it's what condoms not the healthy it's a
poor choice but I do feel like this is I
think where the discipline kicks in is
whenever I do anything physical I feel
like okay I'm entitled to a reward now
yeah you don't interest mentality right
like I've worked out so I burned all
those calories so I can I can I'm
entitled to a treat yeah of course what
you're living the lifestyle that you
live you're always doing something
physical so that's the mentality you
have you're going like well I was
treating yourself treats for days sounds
great
right sounds great but it doesn't it
doesn't add up
because you could get if you get as big
as you are then you start eating
whatever you want you get fat real quick
oh yeah absolutely I have a feeling you
know if I if I let myself go for a week
or two weeks or whatever it is like yeah
I would show for sure you ever fantasize
about that just going like you know what
what if I just gave up it just allowed
myself to become a big fan yes Oh would
it be great yeah
now of course just let go man no worries
right yeah you got it
look you think about those guys like
they have movie roles with yeah I had to
gain like 40 pounds for this movie role
where I just had to be a fat guy yeah
like it sounds amazing
that's incredible maybe the next
evolution of Elias will be like
overweight Elias just kind of sitting on
the stool and playing guitar yeah what'd
you get what'd you get older you can be
a washed-up rock star yeah and you got
to be kind of fat then right it's got a
natural yeah has anyone done that like a
fat dumpy washed-up character on purpose
I don't think so yeah yeah I think
characters have become fat and dumpy and
washed out I don't know not on purpose
if they portrayed themselves but I'd be
into it who did you grow up watching
like I liked him I mean no jake the
snake' macho man Shawn Michaels Bret
Hart Kurt Angle you know I'm moving up
towards the more current generation but
yeah I mean Shawn Michaels was my
all-time favorite macho man of course
Hulk Hogan Ultimate Warrior I could just
list every wrestler if you yeah I liked
all of them yeah
pretty much yeah I honestly yeah I did
those are my select few you know I mean
like I loved Eddie Guerrero and
so I'll keep going yeah hey Mia did you
do a bunch of wrestling before you got
to WWE I was uh yeah an independent
scene for maybe four and a half five
years okay yeah for sure and the whole
time I was I was trying to get to WWE
that was the whole reason for being oh
yeah that was the goal from the
beginning Dave in the Bronx says he used
your warm-up routine
what's going on Dave what's going on Sam
no I saw his warm-up routine from the
Celtic Warrior workouts and I started
doing that before my workouts and I did
a complete body transformation like I'm
217 now I am very nice 217 like with ABS
which is really hard but yet his warmup
of just like the stretching and and and
the dynamic stuff yeah of course I
remember a man that's uh that's
fantastic that you were able to take
that see that video
I mean it touched your life like that
dude in your you've transformed 217 I
don't know where you were at before but
it sounds like you must have lost some
weight and got in really great shape so
good man I'm glad I'm glad what I put
out there could help in some way look at
what's the warm-up what is it I mean it
starts with a bunch of oh I guess
calisthenics dynamic skipping scooping
hip open stretching things like that
just really gets the blood flowing in
your body prime for for exercise the
cameras nervous talking to you do you
get isn't it we're when people are
nervous talking to you yeah you know I
just I I feel for them because there was
a time in my life where I can imagine
you know I met Shawn Michaels my all
time like favorite when I was like 15
and I was just like beyond nervous right
so uh how did he treat you ah great as I
say it's very very cool and actually I
told him was a he make me want to be a
wrestler that was odd to tell him that
so but yeah so I think it's never gonna
happen but you know so whatever people
are you know nervous or whatever they
don't know what to say or do I
understand you know what I mean so it's
a little uncomfortable at times but I do
understand and I know I feel for so you
do the independence for four or five
years then you end up in NXT which is
primarily based in in Florida but does
some travel yeah not WWE level travel
but doesn't know but they do road road
shows if you get to WWE where I mean
it's nothing but travel all the time um
and just show show show and like you
said the pace that the stories are
moving and the things that you're doing
or moving is it's insane it's like
nothing else in entertainment uh what
was kind of the biggest shock or or what
left you kind of the most like okay I
got it I got to get used to this and I
got to get used to it now a man it's
that's kind of a you know I do get that
question sometimes but it's a it's weird
because as a fan of wrestling I wasn't
just like watching Monday Night Raw and
then I was like tuning out the rest of
the week I'm like studying what it's
about right so nothing is really like
Oh catching me off guard here you know
what I mean
I kind of knew oh yeah it's a total
grind and you're traveling all the time
and it takes its toll well you know what
I mean so in televisions live television
it's a crazy environment but it's not
totally caught me off guard you know
what I mean totally yeah yeah isn't it
live on the great though cuz you know
there's no net so if you [ __ ] up that's
just that there's something great about
that live performing I mean that's
there's just exactly you just said it
right there
yeah it's over you don't have to go back
and try to touch it up it's like whether
you did it right or you did it wrong all
we can do is think about what we're
doing next time anyway was there
anything that you got into and you're
like okay I know how this works or I
have a pretty good idea how this works
and then you saw it firsthand you said
this is totally different
man um again I don't I don't think so
yeah of cook it's just you know I catch
myself in moments where I'll get
stressed out or I'll get angry or
whatever it may be because of the whole
process and then I catch myself and go
oh yeah this is what I do you know what
I mean this is all a part of it so yeah
yeah this is just part of the gig yeah I
guess you have to maintain that
philosophy right regardless of what like
this it's not like we're you're brought
here just to jump in a ring réseau punch
in and punch out and you're done like
this is a whole lifestyle it's job
definitely not that man you know even on
and if we get a day off it's not like
I'm just checked out I'm living it all
the time do you like when the
celebrities around like when you got a
Colin Jost and Michael che that are
gonna be in the Andre battle royal at
WrestleMania and then and they're
involved with braun strowman and whatnot
i mean or do you prefer when it's like
let's concentrate on on the wrestlers
that have been here yeah I'm always I'm
always for focusing on the talent that
we have and making them the best we can
and making them be the biggest deal we
can if a celebrity comes in and it's
gonna help elevate or bring more people
were you know more more eyes on the
product then yeah let's do it I'm game
for it let's make it great somehow you
know what it means
yeah so I go back and forth on if I
think it's better but as long as it goes
back to the talent that is there night
in and night out then that's when you
like yeah
Colin Jost and Michael che come in and
we're all about just let's make those
guys look great and then move on that
don't do anything for anybody as far as
I'm concerned right but if they come in
and it makes braun strowman look great
and more people see WWE and it's a good
interaction okay cool
we'd like to throw a celebrity around
wouldn't that be nice Bradley Cooper
came in to promote a star is born or
something like that and you just got to
smash something over his veil I would I
would love if he came in yeah nah he's
like playing guitar and singing and
stuff right right would be all right you
know you know I don't like the Bradley
Cooper does that right and everybody's
acting like he's a real singer now yeah
and I'm going I don't see what's the
difference between an actor who can
because it's not like he's this amazing
singer-songwriter he can pull off
singing I don't see what's the
difference between an actor that can do
that
yeah and a guy like Elias who's a
wrestler that's been doing that this
whole time nobody's making this big
commotion Wow you know that's uh that is
the stigma around WWE you know what I
mean you just if it's on WWE TV people
are gonna think it's just oh I don't
know a goof yeah it's just all whatever
yeah but you know anybody that really
knows the product they know there's a
lot of talent on that show a lot of
talent on our roster and you know it's
it's really unlike any other form of
entertainment have you met anybody
that's been like I'm a huge fan of what
you do and you're like what the hell you
yeah Bruce Springsteen no yes that's
amazing yeah it was great man so what
did he say he said like I'm a fan he
said hey man I know what WWE stands for
did he really so I was like dude great
where did you meet him great
I listened it was it was I was in New
York filming my documentary at the time
we were doing something at the garden he
was there it was a brief interaction but
man but the fact that he knew who even
who you were and appreciated it enough
that he knew the catchphrase of course
saying enormous yes right and I you know
I love Bruce Springsteen and have my
whole life so to have that right there
as very cool do you think sometimes
about like
figuring out how you can take the Elias
character that like is kind of an
attraction right in the sense that
you're performing you're singing you're
doing it's it's there's an act here and
and moving it so that you can be the
person who's main eventing against brock
lesnar or somebody like that yeah and I
you know I really think that's just a
matter of opportunity kind of coming my
way which I'm I'm ready for when they
when the opportunity comes I'll be ready
for that so I don't know how its viewed
otherwise but for me I think it's just a
matter of switching switching gears you
know and just being ready for all of it
yeah do you have nights where you're
like this is this went terribly I
shouldn't be doing this yeah I mean yeah
I think like no matter how long any of
us are doing it whatever we do yeah some
days we leave going boy to our state oh
my god I'm terrible everybody's probably
their own harshest critic yeah so yeah
there's definitely elements of that
where we want to make everything great
yeah anybody who's good like people who
go and go done it really doesn't occur
to me I'm just you know I go out there
and I'm confident in everything that I
do I'm probably you're probably not that
good then you know I mean oh yeah I feel
like you people were their own sell
their own harshest critics yeah are
generally the ones that end up being
better off for it makes sense I mean
it's torture but they're better off for
you Jim that does occur to you sometimes
yeah have you started have you started
writing for your for your WrestleMania
music I mean the last pay-per-view I
thought it was it was pretty exceptional
because you ended up what did you have
like three segments at the last time at
4-4 actually where is like interstitials
where it was almost like Elias was there
with his guitar
yeah explaining the story of the night
yeah as we went on sing a song about
whatever just occurred yeah talk about
the city a little bit and then move on
and then I have another you know one of
those later on in the night or whatever
so that was super fun
yes I've got ideas for Wrestlemania for
sure and do you do a lot of your own
writing yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah it's
like when it comes down to the music and
things like that there's only so many
you know people that could help you with
that kind of thing you know so a lot of
these words they're just coming from my
head man have you have people presented
you like writers whoever it is presented
you songs that go like I was thinking
this could be your song and it goes like
that
no because right off the bat you know
right off the bat when I get to Monday
Night Raw they kind of understand that
it's different right so they'd rather
come to me and see you know what does
what does Elias want to say what does he
want to do what's the music like and
then they can help from that point on so
there's always ideas being thrown in the
mix but nobody's insulted me in that
that fashion there they come up with a
crazy song you would take it as an
insult Duff oh yeah like you have no
idea what I do yeah what are you
thinking who is your if you could say
like okay we are going to do something
we're giving you a match at WrestleMania
Elias who do you want the match to be
with man you know like those guys that I
messed with last year John Cena and The
Undertaker just those guys are big-time
Wrestlemania names and at WrestleMania
that's where you want to be right in the
big time right there so that's it for
sure when people when you when you came
on board and real quick started getting
a lot of camera time and and started
getting your own segments and all this
stuff and it was going well so you got
more and more did you get side eyes from
people that have been there a while and
maybe weren't getting those
opportunities go and who's this guy
where'd he come from and who do you
think he is you know not to my face
anyways you know what I'm saying I feel
like everybody's kind of at least seen
what elias's and they the big thing is
the crowd reactions right it's like
almost you can't deny that so even if
you're sitting there and you're going
like man this guy's only been here six
months or a year and I've been here it's
hard to deny what you're seeing you know
what I mean right if it's working it's
working yeah right and I think everybody
kind of understands that and like I said
to my face it's all been cool but
I wouldn't be surprised if it was
otherwise one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM app
[Music]